thanks so much for being here i love it
when you come on the show thanks i have
a great time
here
i do yeah i know you do that's uh that's
great uh
aubry i want to ask you about a picture
that i saw that confused me uh
you were on the set of parks and
recreation and
uh you're with your co-star amy poehler
and something's going on maybe you can
tell us what's happening here
there's a lot of hugging and then your
leg starts to wrap around
amy poehler and uh curious what's going
on here
when i hug someone my legs like
instinctively
wrap around them really yeah when you
hug somebody your leg really does
yeah not everyone but it's something
that's happened since i was a child my
grandfather
used to call me like monkey and for
every christmas he gives me a
stuffed monkey and he's like you're a
monkey
you always wrap your legs around just
like a
monkey reflex
if you're saying i don't want to get too
personal but say you're like with your
boyfriend and you're hugging would a
legs start to encircle him possibly yeah
both of them would like
and a lot of times i like force the
other person to pick me up
like a monkey would do yes you might
just be really lazy
yeah it's not something i'm proud of
no no i didn't pick that picture yeah
that was paparazzi i guess and
and you guys saw the paparazzi there so
you decided to go with it uh
yeah sure we yeah